[Musique]
je n'ai pas encore franchement l'été et
pour certains c'est même la saison de la
grippe de printemps andré de fort
jacques a rencontré des médecins un peu
parallèle il faut l'avouer pour chasser
la grippe et rendre les messieurs
prévenant il confectionne un beuvrages
aux effets fascinant son nom la brûle à
consommer au printemps les matins de
printemps pour les soirs painting nous
faisons une brûle avec du cognac du
calva de l'armagnac ou soit une union du
pays
si nous avons avec des graines dernière
couloir masson ici et alors nous mettant
quelques règles devenir comme sam et
nous arrosons de cognac ou de calva le
sucre et nous mettons le feu
enseigner est alors ce que nous appelons
la brûle nos méthodes de sucre dans une
cuillère voyez un et tout arrosé de
cognac avec ces graines venir et alors
nous appelons ça ici dans le limousin et
dans cette base qu elle que nous aimons
bien nous appelons ça un chat se grippe
alors que disent les médecins de cette
pratique est bien les docteurs disent
bien sûr pierrot peut-être tu dis que
cet anti grippe mais nous voulons pas y
croire mais enfin quand j'en ai un qui
en docteur palace est le premier à moi
pour soigner une grippe
il faut mettre le béret au fond du lit 1
et vous faites porter à votre femme deux
ou trois bols de brûler et quand vous ne
voyez plus le père est au fond du lit
vous dites nous sommes guéris
[Musique]